5090 review time it's finally time to
talk about everything without any
limitations when it comes to the RTX 590
from Nvidia the newest
Flagship insanely expensive graphics
card but something's
missing okay that's better but
something's still missing that's better
but something is still
missing yeah that feels about right but
it's still not quite enough to buy one
today's video is brought to you by the
new really super cool Jus sense melty
connector shirt you know paying tribute
to one of the best designs that's
clearly ever existed and if you don't
like the paper wave colors we got our OG
gray and red colors available now so get
yours by following the link in the
description below nice ow I have a thigh
cramp okay RTX 590 um this is the first
time we've actually like used most of
the well pretty much all of the new
techniques and methodology that we're
doing to test our gpus I don't ask much
I do ask that you give this video a like
if you appreciate it I've probably put
more than 50 hours into this one review
alone uh that's more than we've ever put
into a GPU review but I think the data
is solid I think the information we're
going to show you is relevant and I'm
really excited for this video because it
it really showcases strengths and
weaknesses that we may not have been
able to find uh in the past anyway the
things we're going to focus on today
performance power draw temperature form
factor cost of performance uplift uh
performance per dollar all of that sort
of stuff so we'll talk about some of the
key features obious obviously it's the
Nvidia Arch uh Blackwell architecture
it's the GB 202 TC uh tsmc 4 NM process
21, 760
cacor that's just an that's just an
astronomical number I don't think I've
ever we've never talked about a GPU that
has had that many cores in fact the most
cores we've talked about in the past uh
was the 490 which had over 16,000 anyway
680 tmus 192 RS 32 gab of gddr 7 at 28
gbits per second effective speed uh
that's obviously an uplift from the 24
GB found on the RTX 490 and the RTX 390
so 32 GB uh it is a true pcie Gen 5
device in fact it is such a true pcie
Gen 5 device that my pcie Riser uh that
we use from elmore's Lab Elmore labs to
measure socket power doesn't work with
the device in fact it crashes the device
so yeah our the new testing methodology
for power now is going to be or relying
on a hardware update hopefully that
comes in the future um anyway uh it also
features an illuminated X on both sides
of the card where the 490 and 390
featured only half the X on one side of
the card uh and then an illuminated um
logo that says GeForce RTX can't find
any sort of uh control for the LEDs on
the card yet the 390 actually was an RGB
card you could actually change it from
white to any other color within the RGB
Spectrum open RGB doesn't really
recognize the card no other software
seems to control it that might change in
the future I don't know if it's a true
RGB but whatever that's that's just
there so uh thermal design it's a
575 watt total board power card that is
insane especially coming off of the
heels of a lot of the concerns and the
ongoing every now and then popping up a
melting connector that you would find
with the 12vt high power now known as
12volt 2x6 because of the fact that
there have been some revisions to that
in fact we've talked about that in
previous videos that uh the connector
was slightly changed the pins were
slightly changed we showed in our
unboxing that there actually was an
improvement to the adapter itself it's
got some actual shielding and armor on
it to keep it from bending too tight to
pull itself out its flexibility now
means that you can uh have more mounting
options in cases where the side panel
might have impacted the cable it
actually has more Bend to it um that's
also aided by the fact that the 5090
features an angled power plug to give
you more clearance and an easier way to
my gen sun is hitting everything right
now anyway uh it gives you better
routing options when it comes to the
cable apparently I am bleeding I have
now bled on my paper how uh but yeah the
575 wat Max TDP when it comes to
overclocking we'll talk about that about
that in a separate video this one's
going to be long enough already with
just the out of the box type of
performance uh but just kind of a high
level you do get 4% of additional power
limit you can go from 100 at
575 to 104% which actually works out to
uh just under 600 watts now we do have a
power draw section of this video you'll
see it actually does Spike quite a bit
above 575 depending on the workload it's
recommended a 1,000 watt PSU um higher
than that might actually be recommended
to be honest cuz I was seeing total
system power exceeding 800 watts in
certain workloads with this card on a
9800 x3d which is our test bench if
you're running a high core count CPU or
something more power hungry like an
Intel CPU pulling 253 Plus depending on
your board and your configuration uh you
can easily hit that th000 watt limit and
maybe run into some ocp or overcurrent
protections shutting down your system
depending on your workloads so 12200
watt might be really the more optimal
power supply for that at the very least
if you're running 1,000 watt make sure
it's a high rated power supply something
that's got you know solid capacitors
something that's either running a high
80 plus rating or even a cybernetics
rating to make sure that you're getting
uh you know all of the all of the power
that you're going to need for this uh
when it comes to the dimensions though
it is 3 4 mm long it is 137 mm tall and
48 mm thick it's obviously a two slot
design a true two- slot design we
already talked about that overall
exterior Dimensions matches 3090 and
4090 it's just not a three slot or 3o
two slot card so there's a lot of
discussion about it being so small it's
really not that small it's actually just
that much narrower really um that's
because it also does feature a
blow-through design a 3D Vapor chamber
with liquid metal for cooling the the
die but it is a flowthrough design which
means the PCB is in the middle it's a
three-part PCB the output is a uh
connected component to the PCB and the
PCI Express um Riser K or excuse me the
PCI Express slot is also uh a separate
PCB from the main board so there's three
pieces to it flow through design um very
low impedance when it comes to the fin
stack it is a tighter fin stack at only
1.6 mm of of gap between them which
means it's a tighter fin array than on
the 490 doesn't make any crazy turns um
that also has this concave in the middle
that's reducing the amount of resistance
across uh where the pressure drops are
and aren't based on the fan design so
it's actually a really neat very well
thought out cooler given the fact that
they're reducing the slot thickness they
definitely uh had to make sure that
their efficiency was there uh let's see
let's talk about weight real quick um it
is actually lighter than the 490 even
though it feels heavier to the hand
because it's denser it weighs in at
1,836 G the 49 by comparison
2,178 G so it is a lighter GPU overall
and in my opinion it looks nicer with
the darker gunmetal color versus the
more bronzy color that you find on the
40 series and 30 series minus a 480
super which is actually black let's go
and talk about our test rig uh so it's a
9800 x3d overclocked to 5.3 GHz locked
does not fluctuate the GPU does not go
or the CPU does not go up and down based
on GPU load it is just locked um we're
running the the gskill well 32 GB of
gskill 6,000 MHz cl28 36 gaming
RAM on an x870 e taichi uh ASRock
motherboard now all of our tests are a
three run average uh we are including
not only average FPS we are including
99th percentile and 95th percentile so
the way that you need to look at these
charts and realize the way 99 and 95
Works cuz you're probably used to seeing
1 and
0.1% 99 percentile means 99% of the
frames are that FPS or better the 95th
percentile means 95% of the frames are
that FPS or better so it gives you a
real um better look at what the overall
per performance of the card is going to
look like and what the dips and lows are
on average um fun fun fact and spoiler
alert it does really really well so
here's what we're going to do we ran
nine different titles at three different
resolutions and there are way too many
charts to sit here and go over each one
um we're just going to run through them
right now we're going to put them on the
screen only put them up for a couple of
seconds pause the ones that are most
interesting to you is an entirely new
testing suite for us the only title uh
that's not a synthetic that is held over
from previous testing is Borderlands 3
everything else for us is a brand new
title uh and a lot more modern and a lot
more relevant so let's run the
benchmarks now obviously if you're
running 1080p uh it's going to be pretty
easy to start running into CPU
bottlenecks I would not say this is a
very solid 1080p card unless you're
running a title that absolutely
positively must have the most FPS no
matter what uh I guess some eorts titles
are that way I I don't I don't run any
of those titles so I really couldn't
answer or speak to the needs of that but
this is a 4K card and a 4K card alone as
far as I'm concerned even though we
tested 1080p in 1440 so obviously in
1080P the lead over the RTX 490 is
smaller than the lead in 4k um also too
all of our tests pretty much ran um
non-frame gen and only small amounts of
dlss I wanted to see what the true horse
power uplift is between the 490 and the
90 now the median uplift in raw
performance uh is 32.4% across hour
testing in 4k I only did median uplift
in 4k 1440 and 1080p have too much
opportunity for CPU bound to rear its
ugly head so if we're looking at 4K
ultra settings across the board to see
what kind of uplift we were getting uh
by being as GPU bound as possible yeah
32.4% let's talk about that for a second
so historically GPU uplift same tier to
same tier when it comes to generation
versus generation with Nvidia is
typically about 25% now that might seem
like oh hey they threw a bone and are
giving us at least in J's tests and
these are obviously going to vary some
of the up some of the tests were in the
low 40% uplift some of them were in the
the mid to low 20% uplift depending on
the title and its efficiency when it
comes to the engine to lever leverage
the horsepower that the the graphics
card can provide so our median is
32.4 if we take into consideration the
uplift between 390 and 490 that was 81%
in our tests at the same cost don't
forget the 590 does come in at
$11,999 MSRP for the founders Edition
you can pretty much guarantee every
single aib card is going to cost more
than that which means you're uplift and
performance uplift per dollar which
we'll talk about that calculation in a
second performance per dollar is going
to look even worse than what we're about
to show you right now but the 390 was
15.99 and the 490 was $15.99 Founders
edition cards yes obviously the price
really fluctuated a lot throughout its
life cycle over the last two two years
or slightly over 2 years
so it's 25% more expensive than the 490
to give you
32.4% more performance which actually
works out to only
5.91% more performance per
dollar compared to the 81% additional
more performance per dollar because
there was Zero cost change from 390 to
490 it is not the greatest value
proposition at least for gamers there is
use cases for this card outside of
gaming we'll talk about those in a
moment but 4090 was one of those cards
that a lot of people were just like this
is ridiculous it's so expensive why does
it exist but when you really compared it
generationally between 3090 and 490 you
got nearly double the performance at the
same
cost that does not exist with the 5090
now obviously this is costing a lot to
manufacture they've relied heavily on
software/hardware improvements that take
place on an AI upscaler SL multi uh
frame gen to really showcase what
they're looking at doing in the future
so once again this is a card that is
kind of like the first in what the
future tends to look like and I think a
lot of Gamers right now are really kind
of upset about that because this is
where the whole discussion of fake
frames versus real frames come in now we
did real frames in all of our testing
here I did run one test uh of cyberpunk
2077 where we turned on multiframe gen
and we ran it with 2x 3x and 4x and when
you turn and we obviously ran the 490
with multi gen excuse me frame gen on
remember 490 does not get multif frame
gen that is a hardware level feature
that exists only on 50 Series so frame
gen exists obviously on the 40 series
but it is only one AI interpolated frame
where you can add one two or three
interpolated frames on top of the
rendered frame with the 50 Series card
so if you look at this chart you can see
it jumps out and then jumps out by a
factor of one and then by another factor
of one it's it's pretty much doubling
the frame rate every time well it's
adding that frame that initial rendered
frame again every time you increase the
frame gen from 2x 3x 4X what I want to
point out on this chart though is you
got to take our one our 5% and 1% low or
95% and 99% with a grain of salt I'm
waiting for a discussion with Intel
regarding present Monon because what
we're seeing here it appears to be
showing the 95th percentile and 99th
percentiles uh based on the rendered the
truly rendered frame by the game engine
not by the card so that chart's kind of
showing two different things it's
showing the average frame rate based on
the rendered frame as well as the
interpolated frames for your output
visual frame but it's showing the 1% and
5% lows as the uh only the rendered
frame which the game engine is doing not
the GPU so I'm waiting to have a
discussion with Intel about how to make
that data more accurate in terms cuz
it's that might say wow you're getting
20 what 91 or 201 FPS but then you're
getting 46 FPS as a low that's not what
it actually felt like or looked like so
I think that's just a reporting error
when it comes to the software one thing
I want to talk about though when you
turn on frame gen you get in increased
latency the reason being for that is the
only movement that's happening in the
game engine is based on the rendered
frame the interpolated frames are not
taken into account input WD space bar
Mouse and all of that only the rendered
frame and then youve got the inserted
frames before the next rendered frame
where it takes that input and then draws
it Nvidia reflex is turned on by default
when you turn on frame gen so it's
improved and they have made improvements
to that when you the one thing I cannot
really display for you or show you
because I'm not equipped to is the
actual latency between click to drawn
frame or click to Photon whatever you
want to call it um I can tell you I
cannot I cannot relate to a feeling but
the feeling of the frame rate is still
going to feel like the base frame rate
rate so for instance in cyberpunk 2077
the base frame rate before turning on
frame gen is 60.2 FPS even though we are
getting a displayed frame rate of 2001
the input is going to feel like you're
still at 60 FPS so you're going to get
what feels like kind of a jelly a
slightly jelly feel to
it it's not this is where we're very
subjective at this point of the video
both Phil and I agree it's play
it's not terrible it's better than what
it felt like on 40 series however it's
still there it's still noticeable if you
were playing a title like rocket League
let's say rocket League had multiframe
gen that would be terrible because every
frame matters in a game like rocket
League every frame matters in a
competitive title so single player games
I know Star Wars Outlaw cyber punk
control Indiana Jones these games are
games that I would be able to turn on
multiframe gen and not feel like I'm at
a disadvantage or I'm at some sort of a
handicap when it comes to input uh
latency but perform like but competitive
titles I would absolutely personally not
run it so that's why I was very adamant
that I'm showing raw performance when it
comes to our testing including RT on
without even running uh dlss in most
titles some of the titles I was running
dlss at a 66% uh Bas frame or excuse me
base resolution but uh Once you turn on
the multiframe Gen yeah it is very
smooth on screen but seeing things move
on screen and then seeing them react to
your input are two very different things
that is why people are upset that is why
people are calling these fake frames
because the game is not rendering the
frame the GPU is doing it after the fact
so important to point that out that's
all I'm going to talk about with frame
gen that's all I was prepared to talk
about today when it comes to frame gen
it's going to be a bigger discussion in
the future that is the way Nvidia is
going if you don't buy into that then 40
series even though it has frame gen it's
kind of your last stand before you're
forced into it moving forward it's kind
of like RT now RT when it first came out
everyone's like it's a gimmick it's a
gimmick no one cares now every title
supports RT one thing I want to point
out though well almost every title one
thing I want to point out though is
right now at the time of testing only
about five or six titles support
multiframe gen natively in the game
engine itself there are 75 titles that
Nvidia is going to say are available
that support multiframe gen at
launch but just about 70 of those are
relying on the in the Nvidia app to
override and do it on a driver level
rather than a game level we didn't test
any of that I'm not prepared to I need
more time to get comfortable with that
before we can determine whether or not
there's any sort of weirdness that takes
place when the driver's handling
multiframe gen versus the game engine I
think personally the game engine
handling it would be a better experience
but obviously this is kind of like a
Band-Aid to sort of bridge the gap
between multigen being the future with
AI interpolated frames from Nvidia
before game developers can implement it
at a uh coding level so I guess we'll
have to wait and see what the future
holds there now dlss 4 isn't only about
multiframe gen um actually 40 30 and 20
series are going to be getting dlss 4 as
well it's just they're not going to be
getting multi frame gen so 40 series
will still have frame gen 30 series and
20 series will have no frame gen because
again that was a hardware level
generation issue just like multiframe
gen is a hardware level thing for 50
Series but you the 40 30 and 20 series
will'll get all the Fidelity
improvements when it comes to the
Transformer model instead of the convert
con convolutional convolutional what a
word is convolutional neural network uh
model when it comes to the AI upscaler
now to the transformative model which is
actually the same thing g chat GPT uses
now to generate its images and stuff so
it's actually doing a better job now at
sharpening up the image Den noising uh
there's less smudges and less traces of
you know distant text doesn't look as
fuzzy anymore it's still not perfect
it's still going to have some uh Trails
Left Behind when it comes to NPCs or
cars moving in the distance 40 series 30
series and 20 series are getting the new
transformative model built into dlss uh
but only 50 Series gets the multigen
aspect of that so the discussions of
yeah dlss looks terrible whatever uh
it's improving it's still not perfect
but it is improving uh and I just wanted
to point that out because someone did
actually request that we talk about how
terrible dlss looks
I don't know I think dlss looks way
better than I remember day one and how
DL dlss looked it was it just kind of
looked like you were looking through um
film graen in a movie and anytime you
moved it was all sparkly it was terrible
but it has improved and we'll see how it
moves forward now on the transformative
model versus the convolutional neural
network all right so let's talk about
frequencies real quick so the base clock
is actually 2017 MHz which sounds very
low uh and a boost clock at 2407 now
because of GPU boost algorithms it'll go
much higher than that actually we saw in
game gaming an average of about 2650 MHz
when it comes to the frequency under
gaming loads but we tested it with a
couple of different scenario so I use
Stalker 3 excuse me stalker 2 at uh 4K
with epic settings I'm trying to push it
as hard as I possibly can stock fan
profile uh if you look at this chart
right here you can see it's at about
2650 MHz averaging over 2600 which means
we're getting nearly 200 uh MHz
additional boost clock over what's
advertised just simply because of
cooling head room power headro Etc uh
but if you look at the pink line on here
that's actually furmark furmark is a
very difficult test to run in fact it's
been known to actually damage cards in
the past that weren't capable of
throttling themselves well enough as
they're trying to render all the fuzzy
donut that's going around and around in
circles um and the reason why it's so
fluctuating like like that on the chart
is because of the fact that the doughnut
is turning and there's different parts
that are harder to render than others so
it's a pretty stressful test um but you
can see the test started out at about
2200 MHz and dropped down as low as
2,000 now in between 2 and 2100 now a
little caveat to mention with that
though a lot of GPU manufacturers know
that furmark is notorious for being very
difficult to run on cards so more often
than not uh there might be logic built
into the GPU or the driver that says if
running fir Mark downclock it's kind of
like when running cin bench some
motherboards and CPUs will automatically
run like an AVX offset to reduce the
frequency in the CPU because of the
difficulty to run the test it's designed
to keep things from getting too hot too
out of control or causing any potential
damage so I just wanted to point that
out the load does kind of jump around
but in games across pretty much all of
our games we saw uh 2600 MHz on average
and above when it comes to the game
clock so that's that's a testament to
how well the cooler is actually
performing all right so testing
conditions for temperature now that we
sort of talked about that our room temp
is 22c uh very temperature controlled or
about 72° Fahrenheit uh you can see on
our test bench it is an open air test
bench on open uh bench table is what
it's called so the only thing impacting
temperatures is the cooler itself it
also is in a vertical orientation in our
test bench not a horizontal uh but if
you watch the interview Steven at Gamers
Nexus did with Malcolm from Nvidia which
is the thermal engineer and cooler
engineer um they test it in all
orientations and because it's a 3D Vapor
chamber it really doesn't matter what
orientation you put it in but ours was
in a vertical orientation which is uh
worth pointing out anyway
um the stock fan curve does have a zero
DB mode so at idle it run about 32 to
35c depending on your ambient
temperature with the fans off uh the max
percentage I saw our GPU uh fan curve
get to in our open test bench is 48%
which capped our uh temperatures at 77 C
and once again it's important to point
out that these temperatures were tested
in fmar because in my opinion these are
going to be the worst almost the worst
conditions they could possibly
experience when it comes to load uh but
77c was also the highest I was seeing in
any of our game uh benchmarks all of our
tests are recorded and every single one
of them have data that we can go and
reference it was pretty solid that 77c
was about the hottest that we saw it get
to in an open air uh chassis fun fact in
the small little case that we did a
building we saw it get up to 80 we'll
talk about that in a separate video I I
told you we'll do that but there are
some testing we have to do to figure out
the configuration where it runs the best
but right now it'll get up to 80c uh
which is only 3C hotter than the open
air testbench but that also required
much higher fan curve so we'll talk
about that in a separate video um but if
I app apply an MSI After Burner fan
curve by looking at this chart right
here which has all three here including
100% fan curve it drops all the way down
to 73c average with 71 low and then 100%
fan speed 64c is our Max with an average
of 62.5 so at 100% fan speed which is an
additional 52% fan speed over what the
stock fan curve was at 48 you can see
drops it all the way from 77 down to 62
or 15c average drop that is huge
obviously the Nvidia fan curve is
favoring Acoustics and noise over um the
temperatures itself now that's a pretty
Far Cry from the 90c Max uh temperature
that the GPU is allowed even with the
higher fan curve and a small chassis 80
is not terrible so you're going to want
to make sure though that you're and that
your chassis is capable of exhausting
all the heat let's talk about why the
previous design uh and this is going to
be very similar to if you're running
like any sort of the aibs with like
triple fans or now four fans or whatever
every single bit of the air 100% of the
heat is being exhausted into the chassis
when you take a look at the asymmetrical
design of the previous gens half the
card was a flow through half the card
exhausts its own heat so now every
single bit of the heat needs to be
exhausted by the case so you need to
make sure that your case Cooling and Air
Flow exchange rate is adequate enough
for this or your temperatures are
obviously going to be significantly
higher an open air test bench we do it
this way that way we can say exactly
what the cooler limitations are not what
the case Li limitations are there's no
case I could test this in that would be
significant or relevant enough to
everyone to say this is the one that
matches most people's scenario so we
test open test bench only but when it
comes to noise though the um the F the
fan blade design the double flow through
the fact that you're not hearing the
turbulent air change direction change
it's actually much more pleasant on the
ear but what I want you guys to hear is
the difference in uh not volume but the
pitch pitch and the acoustic design the
AC acoustic nature of sound is more
important than the volume of the sound
when it comes to something like this and
we find that the fan blades and the
sound of the air going through the 590
is much smoother and much less intrusive
than what we find on the 490 so I'm
going to lock the fan speeds right now
at 65% and let you hear an AB between
the way that the cooler the cooler fins
blades and fan Arrangement sounds
between both of these
okay so let's go and talk about power
draw um that's an interesting one I
already explained that I wasn't able to
use our riser to capture whatever power
is going through the socket some is
going through the socket how much I
can't actually tell you the card
legitimately would not run run with this
on there in fact it was so bad the
system was actually hanging even just at
the desktop so uh what you're looking at
here is our Char power draw chart from
furmark again at 4K this is a 10-minute
test and you can see two lines on here
the pink line which is just a solid 575
watt line is what the card itself is
reporting back as as to what it's using
that's software measurement however
using our pmd2 device and actually
measuring the power going through the
cable itself you can see it's a lot more
fluctuating than that and you can even
see a few spikes on there that are
significantly higher than the 575 watt
TDP limit if we zoom in on the chart um
you can see most of the blue line which
is the PMD measurement measuring the
12vt high power itself resides above the
575 watt TDP line so this is why it's
important now that we use Hardware
monitoring when it comes to power test
rather than what is reported because the
GPU only reports 575 if it gets that
high in game test however uh it uses
significantly less around 500 to 520
Watts now it's weird to say that's less
cuz remember the 490 was a 450 watt card
and we know what happened to the 12vt
high power cable with that one Speaking
of the 12vt high power cable I need to
point out and it's impossible to
demonstrate this for you for you to be
able to feel it the insertion force or
how tight the plug is in the 5090 is
significantly improved over the 40
series if the 40 series I always talked
about it had too much wiggle and too
much flexibility and movement which
could lead to a situation where the
cable starts to back out slightly you
make poor contact and that was often
what was leading to The Melting
connector issues with
490s this is significantly tighter like
I want to enter a very derogatory
reference to give you an idea of just
how tight it is you can fill in the
blanks but when I had Phil insert it for
me his exact response was holy in
fact Phil went to put it in with one
hand it actually required two hands this
is just a friend okay don't forget this
is just a friend use this
cable plug that into the
5090 oh
okay am I going to break it no okay
that's what she said this this is
actually pretty
hard this is quite difficult but I
didn't hear it snap in is it is it in
yeah it's
in so that scientific test has now been
demonstrated now one thing I want to
point out is it's not just the cable uh
taking our 12vt high power that is from
our Corsair power supply has the same
level of insertion for so I think the
actual female end itself uh has become
tighter all right I'm going to get off
this section here before I get myself
demonetized moving on so strengths of
the GPU I mean it's extremely powerful
the raw performance is there um it's not
as nearly as much of a generation jump
as we talked about between 390 and 490
that was 80 plus% uplift in performance
at the same cost this is 32.4% more
uplift in my test at 25% more cost
giving 5.91% performance per dollar
increase which is I mean at that point
if the performance per dollar is nearly
that similar your 4090 is giving you the
same it's only giving you what
94.9% less performance at cost per
dollar so it's not really like you
should be running out and updating to an
R TX 5090 uh if you have a 4090 I don't
think this is really intended for
someone with a 490 I think it's intended
for someone that needs the high frame
pool buffer uh to do AI workloads or
develop or AI development it re it if
you look at it it's really kind of
replaced the quatro series a Quattro
series hasn't been updated in a long
time because the consumer cards are now
starting to really move forward into
this whole kind of a new prosumer type
of line that's just falling under the
GeForce name uh but this card is more
than a gaming card it is intended for
people that can utilize its raw
horsepower High you know memory pool for
those types of workloads and oh yeah
it's pretty good at gaming too like
that's really what this card is meant
for the 5080 that is the gamer card as
far as we're concerned this is the I
have to have the best at all costs at
all diminished returns I don't care I've
Got Deep Pockets you're going to buy it
anyway what I'm saying doesn't matter
you've already decided you're going to
buy it but that's who this card really
is intended for I mean it's also
intended for everyone to put into their
$110,000 computer right I mean everyone
has a $10,000 computer with a $2,000
graphics card in there right look it's
$1,599 it is one of the best investments
you could possibly make you bring it
home to your
$10,000 PC entertainment Command Center
isn't that right don't tell me that's
not true don't be ashamed in fact in all
seriousness if you really watched the
keynote you would realize the 5090 was
only ever compared to the other cards
when it came to AI tops I mean it's just
that's the only type of workload they're
even measuring anymore to determine you
know how like RS was the thing everyone
measured back in now tops is the newest
thing apparently um like I said it's an
excellent card for professionals too
that also and content creators that
could use the very high frame buffer I
mean if you do 3D rendering like actual
3D modeling and stuff this would be an
amazing card I've seen a lot of people
online say I'm buying it simply because
I need it for
work and I think given what the Quattro
card cost a few Generations ago5
$6,000 this would destroy those cards in
pretty much all of these types of
workflows um not all of them I mean they
still hold some things back for the
obviously for the consumer cards but it
is definitely a huge Improvement for
people that could use it in those type
of work case uh workflows and and um
scenarios I mean it's just not a gamer
card as far as we're concerned it runs
cooler than expected it runs hotter than
a 490 but it's 125 watt higher TDP it's
expected to it's it runs armor and it's
narrower but again 21760 cicor versus
16,384 I mean obviously you're it's it's
going to run warmer right those are a
lot of cores to do things um the two
slot design and the power plug make it
more compatible with other cases and
such weaknesses expensive like I said
I'm not even wearing enough money right
now to buy one um partner models are
guaranteed to be more probably going to
be in the $2,500 range and above maybe I
mean the astral card from Asus who knows
what that's going to cost but it's going
to have an astronomical price tag with
it I'm sure um that's does anybody else
miss the day when like $50 to $75 was
what the custom high-end card cost was
over MSRP man I missed the old days
anyway it's got a huge power draw 1,000
wat power supply is the
requirement that and like I already said
with me running a 9800 x3d which is not
a very power hungry CPU I was seeing up
to 800 watts power draw for the entire
system when it comes to the PMD uh so
and that's not even accounting for
whatever the PCI Express slot was
actually pulling I guess it's accounted
for in the 24 pin but I digress uh yeah
800 watts in gaming that was crazy so a
1200 W power supply really is going to
be the recommendation and obviously a
high-rated 1,200 wat power supply so you
have a better quality uh internal so it
will definitely last longer other
downsides depending on your case Flow
Design it can run pretty warm like I
said your case is 100% responsible for
exhausting the air from this card that's
not really a huge talking point though
that's true for every card other than
the founders Edition card just about
every other card and 40 series and Below
Founders cards I mean just about every
single AI card is going to require that
all the air be exhausted by the case too
so your case choice is going to matter
as somebody that is a PC Enthusiast I'm
I'm a I'm a PC Building Enthusiast I'm
one of those people that fall under the
like I want the best anyone watching
this video would want a 5090 doesn't
mean you're going to you find the value
in it at $2,000 maybe if it was like 500
bucks I mean yeah then who the heck
wouldn't want to buy it right everyone
wants the performance but the other side
of the coin is how much does it
cost it's not necessarily the best value
proposition for gamers that's why I said
the 5080 is more the card that should
interest you when it comes to gaming so
that's why it's a it's kind of a easy
pass when it comes to Gamers it's just
not worth I mean depending on what
you're doing what kind of games you're
playing you might you might need the
card you know it's a really good card
like it's the best card you absolutely
should maybe buy it okay buy the card
all right just buy the buy the freaking
card already this is still not enough to
buy
it ow